when protests rocked Hong Kong Carrie
Lam said that her controversial
extradition bill would die a natural
death for all that time and for all the
further demonstrations the legislation
has remained stubbornly alive today
though Lam declared its demise
I have almost immediately and put a stop
so the amendment exercise but there are
still lingering doubts about the
government's sincerity or worries
whether the government will restart the
process in the Legislative Council
so I reiterate here there is no such
plan the bill is dead what the
protesters are worried about his
resurrection that's why they demanded a
formal legal withdrawal of the bill
which would allow people to be
extradited from Hong Kong to appear in
Chinese mainland courts under the
control of the Communist Party see
change attend to terms of you know the
death of the bill
but she still with use to which it
appeal if she still insists this kind of
attitude the outcome will be the type of
this city organizes today about more
protests Carrie Lam has completely
discredited herself and her
administration's a lot of people in Hong
Kong do not trust her any longer and
therefore they do not feel that she a
meeting that abuse will no longer be
pushed to does not means that she will
not reintroduce a new version of the
same build again so far the Chinese
leadership in Beijing has adopted a
wait-and-see approach Carol Ann was
aiming to take some of the momentum away
from protesters without being seen to
back down she wants this movement simply
to fade away and so does the leadership
here in Beijing but by failing to make
even the smallest of concessions to what
are quite modest proposals she risks
drawing this out even further
one of the protesters slogans over the
last few weeks has been at oil Carrie
Lam hoped to quench the fire with her
statement today instead she may have
added more fuel Tom Cheshire Sky News
Beijing